[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
andrew we're back at Chilton Gavi where
we were in our season one Korean
barbeque episode lots of fans said that
that episode actually led them to try
Korean BBQ for the very first time so we
thought why not introduce more people to
more technical in cuisine we're really
lucky in Los Angeles to have a ton of
amazing Korean food so to take it up a
notch tomorrow first thing
Korean soups today I'm worth it we're
gonna be trying to three different suits
actually dressed we're getting price
points to find out which soup is the
most worth the edits price the food I
never thought we would get to do on
worth it we are on our way right now to
one of my favorite if not my favorite
restaurant in Los Angeles it is called a
Han baht song town and they specialize
in one product and that is selling town
ox bone green suit with a very beefy
delectable taste we're gonna speak with
Jong about how they make their suits
just to show you how much I love fellow
in town I actually have an entire album
on my phone dedicated to some hometown
okay you wanna see it wow this is also
fun because I can see your skill and
photography improving it also we're
gonna be meeting with my best friend's
Megan Lee there she is an actor singer
songwriter she actually grew up eating
at this restaurant in fact one of my
first times there was with her so you
know it's the circle of life she's
actually your soup grandmother if you
think about that way whoa yeah is that
making my soup daddy
[Music]
Amba is my favorite restaurant in LA
how did hamburg get started hey Johnny
ran or CVS oh joy hey Mon Ami Tom Kubik
started on a OpenSSL kutami in the Oh
Mon Ami Holly Liza open eyes people
enjoy you gotta believe me no I thought
there was a tall plaster and something
shipp internet that I saw you got to
come time that day but when you're
halfway through the song tongue is ox
bone broths ooh yeah
so Builder actin the East I don't care
there okay that go get in the pool there
I'm the cool tile recipe coming in the
Rotunda by combat only serves one dish
one day skull on top that's it why do
you want to just serve one thing honey
me Jim [ __ ] be that about bone vanya
this is Megan Lee hi guys I will order
the mix I'm gonna get the brisket you
should do songs fans which is the flank
that's exactly what I wanted okay let's
do it
you also get complimentary barley Cheers
[Music]
oh it's so fast combat is your spot yeah
see my family used to come here all the
time
so crazy now that we're filming here
make mixes for me thank you so good when
it comes to Korean food the stinker it
is the more delicious it is
and Richard Cheers oh that's okay for
such a simple recipe it has this insane
depth of flavor that I can't explain
it's beefy in a way that steak can't be
beefy
the flavor that's locked in the bones
and cartilage that's not in straight
cuts Wow yeah so we have all these
garnishes what should I be doing here I
love adding pepper how much is enough
going on you know I had a lot I like my
green onions
we have two different kinds of kimchi
this is just regular cabbage kimchi
this is a radish kimchi I personally
think the radish kimchi is the best very
liberal kimchi don't get a moment but
the harmony red sphere how do they
thought I have it earlier Tom Navi they
would interrogate a powerful mandolin
mobile dr. Kenan tonight oh no the
radish is great oh man eating an egg hot
soup
I think my : meat is the greatest
partnership in all of 3-cycle and me are
you the meat and your pickle he's
definitely the pickle I am what happens
when you combine pickle in what I like
to do is actually get a little bit of
the sauce here and the part for it oh
really you do that like halfway through
your soup kind of changing it up as you
go
like with Cheers all right we're gonna
be having our next soup a little bit
later on but first we're gonna stop for
what I think is one of the coolest
places in all of Los Angeles it's called
baru so we're gonna be having some
kombucha and some cookies I mean I'm one
of the owners Baro is the Korean word
for a bowl that Buddhist monks carry the
food is it's in Korean ingredients but
it's a very diverse menu we ferment our
own drinks here visit Japan a fermented
pineapples and then today we have lemon
verbena yuzu kombucha just inoko cookie
and then we have our everything mochi
which is kind of our signature sweet Oh
ah he's like pineapples cider
oh my god there's almost loki bread soup
back in 2012 the late jonathan gold
publishes article on the sixty korean
dishes every Angelina should know he
lists numerous soups which include
Blowfish soup
I'm Chetan cheonggukjang samgyetang
donkey meat guksu soaked warm soup sell
in town
my head is spinning with soups this is
what Korea did what is that can you eat
it will make it a sue next we're now on
our way to honestly one of my favorite
restaurants called spoon by H Yoon is
going to show us her pork belly dumpling
soup this is actually a dessert cafe so
I know we just had a cookie but we're
also gonna be having some dessert there
for my 18 and
dessert cafe grill turn in your delight
area how boy style hi c'mon got a cool
tongue go boom sheep goats right that's
not gonna change
why did you put this soup on the menu
when you really are trying to make
really delicious desserts we started out
as a dessert cafe and then so regular he
was like sure yeah I'm gonna be really
small like tiny humble cafes or bill
clay
so today we're trying your pork belly
dumpling soup man Dooku holiday mañana
mañana de style I take a man to convince
Kimura Banton invoke of Google and
shindig resolve to a new miracle in
diameter so how is your mundo group
different from others that you might
find traditional waited until week so I
look a little cleared we mix all
together
oxtail pork bun meat bun rudin chicken a
good whatever they know it takes like
forever so come to Hong Kong seek a
waiver from the reggae guy paradise kiss
me to forget that I was
and what comes out either we going to do
about Jessica Korean food or the money
towards shut off
oh yeah it's better than good we've both
actually had this suit before it's so
good we had to have it again on the show
and then I glasses steamy dumpling
that's a good-looking deadly it's full
of flavor Stephen it's so rich one of
the things I love is the size of the
dumpling relative to the bowl that you
eat out of check out the pleats you can
tell that it was made with love
it's leading me to eat it that's so
tasty for me this definitely falls into
a category of you could eat it every day
it's so encouraging to eat like urging
it's like Ryung yuan and you're like yes
oh yeah you know what they say to a
party boy Adrienne is fighting you can
do it oh yeah anything in the right way
Peyton we're ahead of dessert cafe we
should have some desserts as well yes
slighty that Mentos photorealism I think
on there it's like a flower bouquet of
grapes yeah yeah when they're two second
waffling they are take a crispy I cook
front choco and then in a computer the
robot Nutella dress all
house-made ice cream you guys make your
own ice cream - yeah oh wow yeah boom go
to Boca be on Cuban each was in the
Mafia moaning when did equipping it -
cool
it's hard to see what kind of services
are you serious this is ridiculous
yeah this is the perfect example of the
attention to detail one Holgrave tiny
slice put into it
tiny sheet of paper inserted into them
oh my gosh the whipped cream dissipated
and it's still being held in place like
a stone arch this is some DaVinci [ __ ] I
you can't eat this it's frustrating oh
yeah whoa wait this is not your typical
waffle what
well is it by press I'm having this
actually really yeah okay
it is somehow fluffy and crispy yeah it
feels like something that a spider would
make oh yeah fighter you think crawly
bugs but then you see its web you know
like how could nature produce such a
perfect shape someone check you in for a
radioactive spider hiding Peter Parker
more like something that I don't know
boon or man
[Music]
it's not in the game cuz it's a super
episode
I love how is just a family doing their
thing killing it but it does mean that
sometimes it takes a little bit more
time because there's all this love put
into the food so if you want to check
out spoon by age please go with a little
bit of patience soup facts
hey jungkook literally means hangover
soup and it is a rich beefy bone broth
dish that can be served at any time of
day Annie didn't you say that your mom
used to make you that soup all the time
what are you just consoling her what's
going on I was not a drunk baby now we
are on our way to our last restaurant
we're gonna see David Chang at majordomo
he is going to show us their whole
boiled chicken multi-course soup dish
because he's a friend of the show he's
going to be joining us for our meal also
because it's quite a
this is a multi-course soup extravaganza
oh my is real name baby please I will
not okay
[Music]
one night knowledge ooh here again you
are a friend of the show we've worked
with you yes but you open this
restaurant in the time that we last saw
you on oh my god I totally forgot about
that that's why when we opened up this
restaurant it was very important to me
that we represented the diversity of Los
Angeles without it being patronizing I
know
Koreatown very well but I don't want to
do anything that was like well come here
to eat cream and I looked at it as
almost like a Venn diagram and we needed
to find that overlap so does that occur
in this dish itself yes chicken that we
boil we serve it in two ways just to
poach chicken breast and then we pick
the dark meat and serve that as a soup
that comes after the white meat Jude
parry sickles is the executive chef
Jude's gonna be cooking the food today I
wanted to serve something that's boiled
because I grew up eating boiled chicken
I have to figure out how to present a
dish that is interesting and cool
because it's not what people expect
chicken to be so I kept on thinking the
image was a trust roasted chicken right
it's beautiful golden-brown and a
corroborate presented in giant copper
pot and I'm like I said just serve it
like that but boil when we first did the
dish the biggest complaint that we had
is it takes too long so we're like okay
I'm just a shoulder
pick the meat and then we put all the
chicken meat in it's too much chicken
meat if I just put the dark meat in I
now have this white meat is there
another poached chicken that I like a
lot like of course I love high knees
chicken for somebody who has no idea
what I mean these chicken is what is
that how would you define just a post
chicken and then served over chicken
right except that's cooked in chicken
stock popular in Singapore and Malaysia
it's crazy how good it is it's always
dependable and there's another dish by
Gabrielle Kamara at Contra Mar Mexico
she has this grilled fish one side is a
red sauce one side is a green sauce I
was like oh serve the chicken breast
that way so we have a chili black bean
sauce ginger scallion
what is this rice and he's in this
chicken nice but it's chicken rice but
it's not I want you to face I'm really
Kerry thank you
mmm you know what makes me want to do in
like Malaysia you see all you think old
guys like this you wanna do that I am
invulnerable it's annoying that this
breast is so tasty I know ha ha ha why
are we roasting chickens at all it's
such a pain in the ass we got so much
mess yeah but again this is the
byproduct we've taken the fat from the
soup and mix it in with the rice
that's braising so this isn't the main
course this is just the byproduct of
this this dish alone I would be totally
satisfied sorry I'm finishing this food
don't worry I'm honors my mom would
literally just put a whole chicken in a
pot of water and just bring it to a
rapid boil the more I learned about
Korean food the more I realized oh
that's the basis of a lot of different
dishes so if you roll out pasta and tear
the noodles and you just cook it in the
broth so it gives it the thickness and
it gets cloudy it almost becomes like
the chicken and dumpling all right in
the American South the dish that I grew
up in Virginia I love that dish but it's
not it's Korean suji P so all of a
sudden now we're talking about four
different dishes in this dish if you
roast chicken on a rotisserie all that
beautiful juice just goes away but if
you're cooking a new soup you get all of
the goodness where truffling the soup
right now so why did truffles make sense
for this dish Wow
can i this is the work that amount
please be impartial to the amount of
troubles when you're judging this in
your minds
why do truffles work in this dish I
think they need to be activated with fat
and keep seasonally right now I'll have
fava beans we have spring peas with some
morels
Wow oh I wasn't expecting to be as clean
as it is pure chicken the broth itself
tastes precisely like my mother's
chicken soup and that's a Ukrainian
chicken soup I am a bit of a seal Wow
the chickens been domesticated the world
over for millennia and millennia yeah
there's only so many ways you can cook
it so chicken soup around the world's
pretty much the same thing so I wonder
have you made this for your mother
here's the thing if I make it for my
mother that's what I'm gonna make her
what I'm gonna make her southern chicken
and dumplings really and you can like
this is JB that's part of your show what
a superb day of soup which soup was the
most worth it to you I just get the
first point this is a hard one I think
of all of the expensive restaurants
there are in Los Angeles
majordomo actually offers some of the
best value this may not come as a
surprise but I have to pick spoon by H
that place truly one of the best
restaurants in all of Los Angeles
it was you're worth a winner my with a
winner goes to hon bot song Tom mm-hmm
moment I moved to Los Angeles in winter
that restaurant I was in love that was
actually the moment I I came to
appreciate Los Angeles Adam once you're
with a winner
spoon by 8 Annie who's your worth a
winner Wow next week we have what is
often seen close by to soup I have no
idea
[Music]